i'm not worried about islamic suicide
bombers they can only do it once a hindu
suicide bomber that is more of a threat
because of the reincarnation
you gotta be easy with women man you
gotta you know because black people you
know we got game naturally brothers we
know how to talk to them
you know we know how to just say that
[ __ ] sometimes if african dudes they
don't know what to say they just so
angry what's what do you call yourself
what is your name you talk to me you say
i'm talking to you in the front row you
don't want to talk to me
[ __ ] you get her and you'll ask me later
[Music]
[Applause]
i think that's some cool [ __ ] i tell you
what ain't sexy is that indian [ __ ] i'm
sorry
indian people you know that
[ __ ] at 7-eleven that is not
sexy [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
ladies you do not want that on top of
you on a saturday night i'm going to
give it to you
i know you wanted your dirty [ __ ] i
know you wanted
i'm going to give you my pakistani beef
you [ __ ]
say my name say punjab it's just
god damn handsome ass indian look at you
are you indian or pakistani indian yeah
relax there's [ __ ]
2 billion of you you don't have to get
that
hindu muslim sick what are you
no [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm saying what's
the background why y'all take so long
for this [ __ ]
from bombay and what you're just naming
more [ __ ] that you know doesn't
what's their religious background
they're not religious either
what about their parents
you don't know them know
you know i know you're lying right you
know
you know i know you're lying right now
none of us ever met a non-religious
indian parent in our life
none of us ever met anomaly indian
parent indian parent non-religious
uh-uh that's what he got to say because
his girl ain't indian that's what
they weren't feeling that [ __ ] were they
what's your back you're asian right miss
what type of asian your taiwanese
that's a good one
nah that's a good one that's like china
2.0
right because taiwanese
right i'm getting that right taiwanese
were like [ __ ] we out
and then they were like japan's too far
let's just stop right here this island
now this island is good we're not going
all the way
you're like those indians that made it
to like trinidad
you know the indians are like we're
going to america and then the first
island they're like [ __ ] it pull over
this is far enough i'm ready
they were so close bro now they out
there in the caribbean thunder clapping
they went from
what about you other indian i don't even
know if you're indian i assume you're
indian
all right what type of indian i am
punjabi punjabi are you sick
you're sick that's what's happening [ __ ]
with six man
those are the dudes that wear the turban
and [ __ ] and they got that bracelet that
little silver bracelet
that's a badass bracelet no for real
because back in the day that used to be
a sheath
that would protect them from swords
because
the six were the warrior class of people
in india
and then over the years you know the
meaning has changed now
it's used to rest on the steering wheel
of an uber but
[Applause]
son if they got that bracelet
locked on that steering wheel
they ain't never crashing dude never
crash it
you let vishnu take the wheel dawg
[Applause]
now that's hindu ain't it that's hindu
did i get that right at least i got that
one
you got that one perfect were your
parents okay with you dating a black guy
they were surprisingly okay with it man
your sister must be a doctor
you got a younger brother and he's doing
everything right
i love [ __ ] that's what's up
that's that brown parents [ __ ] brown
parents don't give a [ __ ] about the
daughter bro
daughter is meaningless yeah it's just
taking up food that the sun could be
eating
bitter bitter donkey chicken your
brother needs some chicken bitter
litter little please bitter please
he's a growing boy he needs it for his
brain
you clearly don't need it because you're
telling black guys
look at all these indian faces jesus
christ
look at you brown bastards god damn
indians just look upset that they had to
spend money to be here tonight don't you
it's a look on their faces
this is [ __ ]
i don't know why i'm spending money to
see someone that looks just like me
i can stay home and look in the mirror
for free we are an endless supply of
cheap jokes
and you know the best thing about it is
indian people were proud of our
cheapness
you're never going to insult us by
calling us cheap that's the best part
you know
you walk up to an inning you guys are
cheap thank you for noticing thank you
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
that guy just called you cheap no no no
he pronounced it cheap
but what he was saying was smart
very smart he was
we're cheap we're you know here's the
thing too it's not like i'm up here
going
you indian people are cheap and i'm the
one that's not no no no no
no no no no no i'm just as [ __ ] cheap
as you
the difference is now i have money
i'm just cheap in better stores
i'll be looking at like an armani shirt
i hate when this happens i'm looking at
a shirt from like a high-end designer
and i flip the tag over and i see made
in india
i'm stuck with a real dilemma i'm like
[ __ ]
do i buy this or do i call my uncle
i wonder if he knows where this factory
is
but now you are performing
where i i don't english isn't the first
language by a stretch
what are some of the places around the
world now that you've been to in the
last year uh i've been everywhere from
like helsinki
finland to uh mumbai india it was uh
yeah and so an idiot thinks oh so all
the tourists that are in town
in mumbai
you're always funny it's the joke i
forgot to do when i wanted to because
all those they're all [ __ ]
telemarketers half of them over there
talking to us
and it's the joke i forgot to do because
it was the last stop on the tour i
wanted to say
i was going to open with that like you
know i probably talked to half of you
[ __ ] already
by the way i know your name isn't cliff
you know but i got i got to tell you man
that i had so much fun
in india how describe please because
they're [ __ ] hilarious people they're
ball breakers
and they're just like i called this
podcast and stand up is new over there
like they're in like their lenny bruce
years like people get in trouble and
[ __ ]
so i called in this podcast i was like
in australia and i called this podcast
to hype the show and
the guys were all comedians and they
they were going like yeah when you come
here you should talk about this
you should talk about politics and mom
well maybe and they just kept
going down that road then i'm like wait
a minute you guys talk about this [ __ ]
and they start laughing
and i go you guys can get me [ __ ]
arrested and they died laughing like
they were just setting me up like it's
not like you would literally get
arrested
but it's like you could get in trouble
like
it's a you you'd have to basically like
singapore i was worried about because i
was like you know that kid got caned all
those years ago
and and i was sitting there
worrying about that and they don't want
you to talk about religion they don't
want to talk about all this [ __ ] but
like if you just
come there right and you just do your
spot and then leave that's not going to
happen but if you if you set up shop
there in every week
they'd have to be getting complaint not
to complain after complaining to
complain then finally it's like a
jerk-off job some guy finally comes down
there it's like hey can you knock it off
can you just stop it so we don't have to
beat the [ __ ] out of you and you're like
all right all right
so it's not it's not as bad